JIS JESS COCAINE PUPPIES,
CRUNCHEN MICE, TRANSGENDER
MONKEYS, FIST FIGHTING HAMSTERS
AND PIGEONS WITH A GAMBLING
ADDICTION.
THESE AREN'T LOONEY TO ANS
VICTIMS OF REAL LIFE SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES PAID FOR BY YOU THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
FOR DECADES DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
NATIONAL'S INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
HAS TAKEN YOUR MONEY AND USED IT
TO FUND DOZENS OF TWISTED
EXPERIMENTS.
HERE ARE JUST A COUPLE.
THEY HAVE SPENT OVER 2.3 MILLION
INJECTING BEAGLES WITH COCAINE.
THEY HAVE SPENT NEARLY A MILLION
DOLLARS TO A SOUTH AMERICAN
YORST TRAIN MICE TO BINGE DRINK
BOOZE IN THE DARK.
FAUCI GAVE 200 GS TO CREATE
TRANSGENDER MONKEYS BY INJECTING
MALES WITH FEMALE HORMONES, THE
REASON?
TO STUDY HIV RATES IN
TRANSGENDER WOMEN?
REALLY?
THEY PAID A COLLEGE IN PORTLAND,
OREGON ALMOST HALF A MILL TO
TEACH PIGEONS HOW TO PLAY THE
SLOTS.
AND THEY HAVE SPENT $3 MILLION
ON A HAMSTER FIGHT CLUB.
THEY MADE NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY RESEARCHES TO JUICE
UP HAMSTERS WITH STEROIDS AND
COCAINE AND MADE THEM BRAWL.
WHY?
TO STUDY ROAD RAGE.
THANKFULLY PET THAT GOT THE
FIGHT CLUB SHUT DOWN.
WORKING ON HUMANS TOO.
THE NIH IS BRIBING GAY AND
TRANSGENDER BOYS AS YOUNG AS 13
TO REPORT THEIR SEXUAL CONQUESTS
THIS IS WITHOUT PARENTAL
CONSENT, OF COURSE.
THESE FRIVOLOUS STUDIES SOUND
LIKE THEY WERE CONCEIVED BY MAD
SCIENTISTS ON AACID TRIP.
WHAT A SADISTIC ABUSE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY, EXCEPT FOR THE
HAMSTER FIGHT CLUB WHICH I WOULD
WATCH.
JUST KIDDING.
JOINING ME NOW VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR A WHITE COAT
WASTE PROJECT JUSTIN GOODMAN.
ALL RIGHT, JUSTIN.
I MEAN, LET'S START WITH THE
TRANSGENDER MONKEYS, THEY DON'T
NEED AN IDENTITY CRISIS.
YOU ARE INJECTING THEM WITH
HORMONES.
THEY JUST WANT TO SCRATCH AND
SWING FROM TREES.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
>> THE NIH IS ADDICTED TO
SPENDING.
UNFORTUNATELY ANIMALS AND
TAXPAYERS HAVE BEEN PAYING THE
FRIES FOR DECADES AS YOU SAID.
THE NIH WASTES ABOUT 20 BILLION
WITH A B $20 BILLION A YEAR ON
THESE TYPES OF WASTEFUL ANIMAL
EXPERIMENTS THAT RANGE FROM THE
STUPID LIKE PUTTING FISH ON
TREADMILLS TO THE IS A DISSTICK
LIKE SCARING MONKEYS WITH FAKE
SNAKES AND SPIDERS SOMETHING
HAPPENING NOW AT A COST OF
$50 MILLION TO TANGSZ PAIRS.
OUR GROUP EXPOSED THAT.
>> Jesse: SCARING MONKEYS WITH
SNAKES?
THEY CAN GET SCARED IN THE
JUNGLE LIKE THAT.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO SPEND
50 MILLION ON IT.
>> THEY WANT TO KNOW IF YOU SUCK
OUT A PART OF THE MONKEY'S BRAIN
THAT CONTROLS FEAR THOUSAND HE
HAD WOULD RESPOND WHEN YOU PUT A
RUBBER SNAKE JETION JES I WILL
SAVE $50 MILLION IF YOU SUCK OUT
THE BRAIN PART THAT FEAR
PROBABLY WON'T BE SCARED.
FISH ON A TREADMILL?
MY 10-MONTH-OLD KNOWS THAT'S
DUMB.
>> SOME OF IT JUST DOWN RIGHT
SCARY LIKE THE EXPERIMENTS INTO
WUHAN THAT ANTHONY FAUCI WAS
SENDING MONEY TO.
PEOPLE SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE ARE ANIMAL EXPERIMENTS
ALSO.
BATS IN THE WILD --
>> Jesse: WHERE ARE THEY GETTING
THE COCAINE TO GIVE TO THE
BEAGLES.
>> THE DEA HAS A STASH THAT THEY
PROVIDE, I THINK.
>> Jesse: THEY SEIZE NARCOTICS
FROM THE CARTELS AND THEN THEY
JUST HAND IT OVER TO FAUCI AND
HE CUTS UP A FEW LINES FOR SOME
BEAGLES?
YOU.
>> I DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF
IT BUT THEY MAINTAIN A STASH OF
COCAINE FOR EXPERIMENTS LIKE
THIS.
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY ARE DOING
THE COCAINE AND COMING UP WITH
THESE WICKED EXPERIMENTS.
WHY WAS THE -- WAS THE DOG
WEARING A LAB COAT BY THE WAY?
>> THEY FIT THE BEAGLE PUPPIES,
THESE ARE 6-MONTH-OLD PUPPIES
FIT THEM WITH THE COATS THAT
INFUSE COCAINE DIRECTLY INTO
THEIR VEINS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO SNORT IT.
>> Jesse: A COCAINE VEST?
I THINK I KNOW WHAT I'M GETTING
GUTFELD FOR CHRISTMAS.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M JOKING BUT IT'S NOT FUNNY.
IT'S SAD.
IT'S REALLY SAD.
AND IT'S A TOTAL WASTE OF MONEY.
I MEAN, WE COULD USE THE MONEY.
BACON IS $10 NOW.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
I THINK FAUCI SHOULD GIVE THE
MONEY BACK AND THE COCAINE TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST AND WE HAVE A
REPORT ON FAUCI COMING UP LATER
IN THE SHOW AND WE WILL HAVE YOU
BACK ON BECAUSE I THINK IT GETS
WORSE.
THANK YOU